bang bang
what's up guys lunch money time thursday
well while she's trying to get rich
russell's just trying to get her lunch
money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
polina evilova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
what up why is it censoring me like that
that's weird okay i i don't know
you got your guns out today got these
got these deadly weapons
don't forget lunch money is now
supported by block five supported
advertised whatever uh
endorsed whatever it is uh make sure you
go to blockfi.com
lunch money they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against it so you don't have
to sell your crypto but you can get us
dollar liquidity
or you can use my favorite product which
is their interest bearing account i'm an
investor in the company
i'm a big time user of the product very
happy user
you can deposit crypto or digital
dollars and earn up to eight point six
percent apy
block five dot com slash lunch money all
right i did it in 60 seconds
or less let's go unemployment what's up
so
new filings for unemployment benefits
last week totaled 1.186 million which is
the lowest level of the coronavirus
era wall street had been expecting more
than 1.4 million
well 16 million americans still are
collecting
unemployment on a week-to-week basis and
here's the crazy part i continue to say
this
the highest number of unemployment
claims
in history before 2020 was in 1982 there
was about 700 or 800
000 unemployment claims in a single week
that was the highest
ever we have had as many as
6.6 million in 2020
per week and we're still at 1.1 almost
1.2 million claims per week
although everyone is cheering for the
1.2 million
number that came out today because while
she was expecting 1.4
and because compared to a 6.6 it's a way
lower number
this would be the single highest uh
number of unemployment claims in a week
in
any other year in history absolutely
insane we
got to get people back to work we
started to open economy
that's bad music no it's construction
oh
that's what our lives come to planet
forgot even what music was we've been
quarantined for so long she doesn't even
remember music
we got to get people back to work the
economies are starting to open but still
seeing 1.2 million americans first time
unemployment claims
that now puts us at over 55 million
americans who have been unemployed uh or
lost their jobs during this crisis
absolutely insane i miss good music
and good construction all right what's
going on with kodak
okay so what is this kodak thing so the
sec
the sec is investigating the
circumstances around eastman kodak
company's announcement of a 765 million
dollar government loan
to make drugs at its us factories
according to people familiar
with the matter so kodak
as you guys know is like a photo company
they have nothing to do with drug
manufacturing
right they got a 700 what a 765 million
loan from the government that on on very
attractive terms to go into drug
development
which doesn't make a lot of sense but
here's the crazy part
that news was announced on a tuesday on
monday the day before there was a
massive
surge in trading volume for the stock
so one day before there's this massive
announcement that happened
and and sorry go on no go ahead
she actually interrupted me so there's
unusual trading activity and it's being
investigated about for
for that but also the sec is reportedly
looking into kodak's disclosure of the
news
it sent a media advisory to outlets in
rochester new york a day before the
public announcement
then asks those outlets to delete the
stories
yeah so look there's probably all kinds
of those issues the two things i care
about
are one why the hell is there a
and when i talk about a big surge in
trading i'm talking about before they
were trading
like tens of thousands of shares and
then all of a sudden they were trading
millions of shares
right like it was a big noticeable jump
the day before this announcement
then they make the announcement on
tuesday and the stock price explodes
over 60 a share and now the stock's
trading at 15 bucks
so what this looks like is this what
just looks like a massive pump and dump
it just and then it dropped all the way
back down 15 bucks
and so the two questions are one who
is making money off this are they
insiders are they not
did somebody get tipped off all that
kind of stuff and then two is
what would happen let's say for example
if the executive chairman or the ceo and
i'm not necessarily saying that they did
this i don't even know who they are
but what if it came out that insiders
were the ones that went and bought the
stock
the day before and then they sold at the
top that would be insider trading
and so there's a lot more no they're not
to than to do that in such an obvious
manner
no way um the one i think was the
executive chairman on television and he
literally was like i don't know why
those stocks should have traded so much
on monday
like we were very careful about what
come on you're
telling me that it just happened to be
the day before a big announcement
you you know 10 to 20 extra trading
volume
and then your stock exploded the next
day and then all of a sudden
a week or two later it's trading at 15
bucks and nobody in the company did
anything wrong
this is fishy the sec will get to the
bottom of it
there's a lot of people who shorted the
hell out of the kodak stock that's why
it's back at 15 bucks
uh they've they made a killing um but
this is just gonna
this is gonna be one to watch we're
gonna talk about this one later and
they're gonna find out who did what
and i'm going to come back and i'm going
to tell you guys don't do shady stuff
the sec will find out what's up with
reels
facebook's attempt to compete with
tick-tock a new short-form video format
on
instagram is rolling oh no rolled out
yesterday to users in the united states
reels allows users to record and edit
short form video with audio and music
soundtracks
similar to what users already do on tick
talk
do you think that they've got a shot yes
because everybody said instagram stories
doesn't have a shot to compete with
snapchat and here we are people are
using instagram stories
i actually think they got a shot i don't
think that they can unseat tick tock in
terms of like tick tock will go away
right snapchat didn't go away but i do
think that this product has the
potential to become very very popular
and it just comes back to you already
have a built-in audience
so if you wanted if you were thinking
about going to tic toc or you just
started
on tick tock and you only have 100
followers but on instagram you have 5
000 followers
then of course why don't i just create
the same content there plus two two
things
one um the tick tock celebrities i've
noticed a lot of them are asking people
to follow them on instagram
not triller or all these other ones
where they have to start over like you
said
also another thing a lot of celebrities
have been trying to figure out tick tock
and trying to build
uh audiences on there a lot of them
haven't been successful
but suddenly if you have a large
audience on
built-in in instagram you can just start
doing your little dances
also one of the things to watch here is
if instagram changes their
algorithm one of the key points to tick
tock was that you could go viral and
build an audience very quickly
if all of a sudden uh instagram can make
a tweak to the algorithm
and you can have some of the same
virality elements to it this product
will become
incredibly popular and so it's all about
they've got
your normal feed of where you upload
things they've got stories
and then and they've kept those two
products separate so you have your
stories feed across the top
and then you can go through your normal
kind of news feed if you will of just
photos and videos that people post on
their profile
if all of a sudden they now take these
tick tock uh
esque reels and the reels are put into
the feed
and you can get virality out of it watch
out
because that thing will explode you
don't think they'll keep them separate
you think it'll be
inside of instagram what's the
difference between
uploading a uh video to your profile
versus reels so here's the thing
i might be super a lot of my friends are
very professional
on instagram like in terms of you know
this isn't linkedin but they post things
that they wouldn't
post on snapchat or something but then
if you add these like tick tocks i don't
know how many of them would be like all
right
my co-workers like watch me nae nae
that's an old dance if you're
whatever that is that sounds like a
horse if you're nae-nae
uh on tick-tock what makes you think
that uh
your co-workers aren't gonna find it
there uh it's just it it's more friction
me if i was on whoo if i was on
tick-tock i'll be in danger
all right what's going on jake paul what
i heard one more thing about tick tock
what did you have
oh no oh yeah um so do you remember do
you remember during the
congress hearing when zuckerberg was
saying all these things like
facebook is an all-american company we
are the quintessential american company
and he was kind of
probably putting in the seeds for
something like this
uh possibly but uh over 85 percent of
their users are outside the united
states some even
at least when i was 86 or 87 percent of
you
but he was telling congress that of
course you know it's an american company
that doesn't share your data whatever
of course all right let's get to the bad
boy of the internet
how did jake paul become the bad boy of
the internet bad boy summer
fbi rolled up if you haven't seen the
video they raided his house yesterday
and they didn't come weak they came with
a whole army guys on trucks hanging on
the sides
with the rifles strapped to their chest
they were ready so
jake paul is a youtube influencer
obviously you need the fbi decked out
for the youtube confluence what is the
swat team
doing at this youtube influencers
calabasas home
it's not a swat team this is a key
different swat team including a swat
team oh they might have brought a swat
team with them but the
fbi this isn't like oh the lapd
swat team this is the fbi rolled up go
on twitter
search jake paul and you'll find the
videos they rolled up literally
holding on to the sides of cars hanging
onto it with rifles strapped to their
chest
with i think i saw four or five vehicles
like 40 dudes
and they weren't there to play around
they rolled up
with business in mind so listen to this
police in scottsdale
arizona on wednesday said they were
dismissing charges criminal trespassing
and unlawful assembly
there against paul and two others so
that a federal criminal investigation
can be completed but that they
me may be refiled later so basically
paul had been charged
uh when he appeared on video in june
inside a scottsdale mall
that a big crowd of people had broken
into looting stores
why is jake paul looting well oh so this
is a key piece
supposedly he didn't do any looting he
claims that he didn't do any looting
and second of all what they could get
them on i'm just
pontificating here is one if they
broke in like it was closed and they
broke in then that'd be trespassing
could be
criminal breaking and entering all these
police one second
second is if he was looting right then
there could be looting charges
third is because he's got such a big
following and he was
videoing it you could see them trying to
create charges like uh
inciting a riot right i mean there's all
kinds of things they can stack on top
the key is just like when you're in the
spotlight you got a target on your back
so when you do things like of course
there could be a hundred people there
but if you're the one who's got the big
audience and you're
the one that's videoing it and posting
it online there's all kinds of things
they may just come after you to prove a
point but that's a lot of
people that's like kind of scary what
why couldn't they send two cops to
arrest them i don't think he's that
violent well so then they uh inside the
house they got a bunch of guns out
oh from his house yeah they confiscated
a bunch of guns there's a there's a
photo online of uh some cops bringing
uh like rifles and stuff out now again i
don't know what the california gun laws
are
uh but what i do know is in america as
long as you follow the law you can have
guns it doesn't necessarily mean he's
doing anything wrong in california can
you have guns
i don't know what the laws are there but
the point being that you know
if you follow the law right you can have
guns it's your second amendment right
the question is anytime that the police
know that somebody has a gun so they
knew there was guns in the home they're
gonna send a lot of people
because it's just like do we think he's
gonna do something crazy and start
shooting at us
no but on the off chance you can you
always want to be over prepared
so if they knew that guns were in the
home okay would make sense why they sent
so many people
we don't know that we also don't know
yet what the investigation is all we
know this was a search warrant
into his house and there's no arrest
made so it doesn't sound like they were
actually
whether he was home or not we don't know
we don't know did they were they there
to arrest them and they just searched
instead
it's all kind of up in the air i just
love the fact that yesterday i got on
twitter and all of a sudden it was like
bang bang fbi race jay paul and there
was videos
it literally looked like a video you
would see in like
um a south american country where the
uh the local police are going into
favela and they're about to
snatch up drug dealers and snatch up
they were riding
dirty all right what's up with airbnb
rural i get hype
it's very hard for me to say this one
word rural
oh somebody else has a hard time
pronouncing things rule
hold on it's not rule it is no it's
rural
rural north carolina oh geez airbnb
bookings are surging as vacationers look
to escape the coronavirus
rural north carolina we see the airbnb
that airbnb you know that that fake
hotel stuff
that yeah they got them people coming
and they just be staying in the hotels
but it's not a hotel it's your house
like we don't call that airbnb where i
come from
instead we just call that your friend
staying over for the night
okay why are they paying to do that they
could just stay at my house for free
oh my god what's going on my god as the
pandemic devastated the global travel
industry airbnb laid off nearly 25
of its employees they raised emergency
debt funding and at least temporarily
shelved their ipo
bang bang they missed their window they
should have gone public trisha mixer
lost over 40 thousand dollars worth of
bookings for her two properties outside
of austin texas when coveted 19 hit
but once the state started reopening in
may she said she was barraged with
requests
all these people ain't want to come the
last few months now all of a sudden
everybody wants to shut up maybe i
should raise my prices
one time he talked like that for entire
day and he made me go through
a drive-through and he like talked to
them like that i was like oh my god
they're good
it wasn't just no drive-through it was
bojangles that's god's food right there
[Music]
[Laughter]
and by the way the best part is the
ladies behind the counter
they thought i really talked like
they're just so used to people coming in
with
you know ridiculous southern draws they
were just like oh yeah they did not even
blink they were just like yeah another
another macon north
carolina guy how you doing there ma'am
can i get me two bow berry biscuits with
a little extra sauce on the side thank
you
a little a little little tea you know
that's the other thing in north carolina
you ain't gotta say iced tea
you gotta say sweet tea you just say i
got some tea and they know tea
okay i'll get you the sweet tea the
sweetness of the tea you don't you don't
have to go
all right so anyway airbnb if you had an
airbnb and you
rented it out you were struck you were
struggling bad
now all of a sudden the demand is back
people want to get out they're tired of
being quarantined
all of our friends are in rural places
rural north carolina all right what's up
with murder hornets
so these damn murder murder harness they
be trying to
buzz me all the time i am deaf in my
right
ear after months of hunting
researchers in the united states have
finally managed to get their hands on
a murder hornet and trap it so murder
hornets were those super-sized invasive
species that were recently seen in north
america nobody knows how they got here
or why they're here they just want to
take our lives
we got a harder time catching the murder
hornets than we do murder suspects
these damn researchers hey man out here
murdering people y'all better hurry up i
said a trap
they said they said a trap is it a trap
so they said this is encouraging because
it means we know that the trap works
they set up over 1300 traps in the state
i don't know what the traps are made of
actually
if y'all needed to catch a hornet you
could have just called me
they always are flying around me i just
walked out in the field and we would
have found all of them in making north
carolina
now the bugs ain't in make north
carolina ain't no bugs out here they're
just our friends they buzz around they
ain't bother us though
we ain't bother them all right what's up
with the joke
um all right hold on let me find a good
one
all right what do you call
a priest who becomes a lawyer wow i just
had some things to say but i'm not gonna
say what do you call a breeze
that becomes a lawyer
think about it
you got it there's no difference they're
both liars
[Music]
[Laughter]
kidding kidding kidding kidding kitty
what do i call a priest that becomes a
lawyer
uh a saint i don't know
a father-in-law ah that's pretty good
that's pretty
a father-in-law there could be better
answers to that one it's a good one
yeah that's a good one do we think that
by the way i was thinking about this the
other day i don't know why do we think
that priesthood like people who want to
become
priests is increasing or decreasing now
yeah after coven because i feel like
religion itself is decreasing but maybe
not like like just the long term trend i
think it is decreasing
yeah i don't know that'd be interesting
to look i'm going to do some research
today all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today while wall street's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get our lunch money right we're gonna
go listen to some bang
bad music outside now you ain't gotta
listen no music
lady you see just listen to my sweet
voice right here
all right guys see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends